فدا شكرا جزيلا لك اهلا بكم مشاهدينا
الكرام في هذه النافذه للتحليل العسكري
لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه وفيها
نستضيف كالمعتاد المحلل العسكري اللواء
فايز الدويري ونتابع بدايه اخر تطورات
المشهد ميدانيا على الخريطه التفاعليه معك
سلام خضر من اين ستبدئين سلام من حيث
انتهى الفيديو الذي نشره كتائب القسام من
خانيونس خانيونس اليوم تشهد معارك عنيفه
جدا والقسام قالت انها تقاتل اليوم
بالرشاشات الخفيفه وهذا ما شاهدناه في
الفيديو اذا اشتباكات من مسافه قصيره جدا
تستخدم فيها حتى الرشاشات وهذا ما اظهره
الفيديو التي الذي نشره كتائب القسام
وايضا فيه استهداف لاليات او على الاقل
لنقله جند اسرائيليه محمله بذخائر وشاهدنا
الانفجار ايضا لمجموعه من الدبابات
الاسرائيليه في منطقه خانيونس الجنوب
عموما هو منطقه مشتعله نقاط الاشتباك لا
لا تزال متوسعه ولكن اليوم هناك اشتباكات
لافته عند جنوب عند شرق مدينه خانيونس
القوات الاسرائيليه لا تزال تحاولوا اكمال
التوغل الى داخل المدينه حتى الان لم تدخل
الى مدينه خانيونس بشكل كبير وهناك ايضا
عمليات متفرقه في انحاء المنطقه الش
الجنوبيه المنطقه الجنوبيه دوما ما تك قرر
اسرائيل
بانها معقل الانفاق الكبيره لحركه حماس
وتقول ان الوحدات الهندسيه تنفذوا عمليات
تفجير لهذه الانفاق وشاهدنا قبل اربعه
ايام او خمسه ايام ايضا رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي زار المنطقه الجنوبيه دون
تحديد المكان الذي زاره لاحد الانفاق بحسب
ما قال قوات الاحتلال ايضا هناك تطورات
بارزه تتم في المنطقه الوسطى المنطقه
الوسطى بطبيعه الحال عده نقاط اشتباك ولكن
اليوم هناك محاوله للتوغل باتجاه دير
البلح التوغل الى دير البلح لم يتم لم
يصلوا بعد الى دير البلح ولكن وصلوا الى
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وهذا المستشفى قريب
جدا هذا يعني بانهم على بان النيه لدى
الجيش الاسرائيلي التوغل الى مدينه دير
البلح كنا قد لاحظنا ذلك بطبيعه الحال من
خلال التحركات العسكريه في الايام الماضيه
كان هناك ما يشبه القوس قوس قتالي في
الصيرات البريج والمغازي كان هناك ايضا
محاوله للاختراق من جهه الزوايده وفتحت
جبهه رابعه ايضا عند المصدر الى الجنوب من
مخيم البريش كل هذا كان محاوله للامساك
بهذه المنطقه بشكل كامل تمهيدا للتوغل الى
دير البلح يبدو ان القوات تقدمت ووصلت الى
هذه المستشفى اليوم ايضا شهد المزيد من
القصف الذي تركز عند المنطقه الحدوديه مع
مع الشريط الحدودي هذه المنطقه تستهدف
بشكل كبير وبحسب الافادات الميدانيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي يحاول ان يدمر ما يقول انها
هذه البنيه التحتيه التي قد تكون متركزه
في هذه المنطقه اليوم شاهدنا صورا مباشره
وقريبه جدا من تلك المنطقه واظهرت حجم
الدمار الموجود في مناطق الوسط المح عايه
للشريط الحدودي ولكن ايضا هذا التطور لا
يوقف ما يجري في الشمال في الشمال اليوم
شهدنا عوده للاشتباكات لماذا عادت
الاشتباكات واين هناك ما نعرفه على الاقل
ان القوات الاسرائيليه تتمركز
الاليات تقريبا عند
خط على طول وعرض المنطقه الشماليه طبعا
العمق ليس ربما تتوغل ل حوالي 500 الى 700
100 متر ولكن لم تعد متواجده داخل المناطق
الشماليه اليوم شهدنا تطورين رئيسيين
شهدنا اولا اطلاق صواريخ وكان هناك ربما
تاكيد على ان هذه الصواريخ اطلقت من
المنطقه الشماليه الجيش الاسرائيلي كان قد
اعلن قبل تقريبا سته ايام بانه انهى العمل
في هذه ال في المنطقه الشماليه ويعتقد
بانه حد الى بشكل كبير من قدرات المقاومه
اليوم اعلنت المقاومه انها اطلقت دفعه
صواريخ ثم دفعه صواريخ ثانيه لكتائب
القسام دفعه وايضا
للسرايا القدس اطلقت دفعه استهدفت المناطق
غلاف غزه الشماليه
وال الشرقيه ايضا وبهذا ايضا نذكر بان هذه
المنطقه عندما تشعر اسرائيل بان هناك داعي
لان تتوغل تقوم ب التوغل اللافت اليوم فقط
نقطه اساسيه
واخيره صحيح صحيفه فورين بوليسي فاينانشال
تايمز قالت ان الجيش الاسرائيلي فوجئ
بمساله لم يكن يعلم بوجودها لم يكن هناك
من دلالات قال انه وجد في منطقه الشجاعيه
نفق تستخدمه سرايا القدس قال ان لم تكن
لديه معلومات بان سرايا القدس تستخدم
الانفاق وبانه وجد النفق في الشجاعيه طبعا
لم يحددوا ما اذا كان ايجاد النفق تم
اليوم ليس هناك من معلومات بوجود التوغل
في الشجاعيه عندما نسمع عن اشتباكات ربما
تكون متركزه عند اطراف هذه المناطق حيث
تتمركز الاليات الاسرائيليه ليلى هذه ابرز
التطورات الميدانيه سنعرف منك واللواء
الدويري المزيد عنها نعم نقاط عديده مهمه
تستحق ان نتوقف عندها السلام لواء فايز
لنبدا من قصه النفق هذه الاعلان عن كشف
هذا النقفه الذي يستخدم من جانب سرايا
القدس هذه المره ما اهميه
يعني
الان اذا كانوا تفاجئوا بان سرايا
القدس لديها نصيب من شبكه الانفاق فهذا
يثبت لماذا نجاع ونجاح المقاومه في مفاجاه
اكتوبر اخر حربين قبل طوفان الاقصى كانت
موجهه ضد سرايا القدس وكانت تطلق الصواريخ
من اماكن مجهوله اين هي الاماكن المجهوله
لو كانت مكشوفه كان يمكن رصد المو
لانه كميه اللهب والامور هذه سيتم تحديدها
بالرادار وبوسائل الرصد المختلفه فان يقول
يعني
هل شبكه الانفاق حكرا على القسام الامر
المتوقع ان تكون لانه سرايه القدس هي
الفصيل الثاني بعد القسام
قد وهذه المفاجاه تاتي بعد 100 يوم من
الحر اذا الحديث كان عن شهداء الاقصى قد
لا يكون لديهم لكن الان الفصيله الثاني
الرئيسي خاضت حربين بصوره مستقله في
الفتره الاخيره بعد ال 21 لوحدها وكانت
تطلق صواريخ تصل الى تل ابيب ولكن لافت
ايضا ان يقول انه فوجئ بهذا هذا ايضا بحد
ذ طيب كانت سلام رسمت طوق ا بالناحيه
الشماليه وقالت انه يعني يفترض ان اسرائيل
كانت تعتبر ان هذه المنطقه خلاص اصبحت تحت
سيطرتها ولكن رغم ذلك الاشتباكات مستمره
وان كانت محدوده فقط ساعدنا ان نفهم كيف
المنطقه الشماليه هي اصلا حدودها الجنوبيه
فمع الطريق عش اللي هي تاتي في اقصى شمال
وادي غزه الى الشمال من جحر الديك على
الحدود الجنوبيه للزيتون يمكن سلام ان
تساعدنا يمكن هي لواء في يمكن هذه الخارطه
اذا اذا نظرت اليها الى الان اين الزيتون
وتل الهواء الخط الذي يقع الى الجنوب منه
مرورا بشمال جحر الديك هذه تسمى الطريق
رقم 10 هي موجوده على الخارطه لواء فز
اللواء فايز ربما الخارطه هنا اوضح نعم
نعم الان الان هذه هذه المنطقه هي على طول
او على عمق المنطقه في
منطقه وادي غزه من الطريق عش الى السياج
الشمالي هذه هي تعتبر القاطع الشمالي
مدينه غزه الكب الكبرى الرئيسيه هذه يفترض
انها دخلت القوات الاسرائيليه دخلت الى
المرحله الثالثه منذ اكثر من 10 ايام و
ولكن انسحابها اخذ اكثر من اسبوع زم من
حيث الزمان لماذا لانه الانسحاب كان تحت
الاشتباك ليس انسحابا طوعيا الانسحاب كان
ب يستند الى قرار سياسي لكنه في ارض
الواقع وكانت في حاله اشتباك بدءا من
الرمال والشيخ رضوان وجباليا ومخيم جباليا
والشجاع والتفاح والدرج وتل الرئيس
وبالتالي بدات تخفف تدريجيا وكانت قمه
الفيديوهات التي كانت تمثل ضربات مؤلمه
خلال ه الفتره وبالتالي اخر موقع انسحبوا
منه كان جبل الرئيس الى الشمال الغربي من
من الشجاعيه الان هذه القوات بقوام فرقتين
و252 انسحبت
وال المعلومات انها انسحبت خارج حدود قطاع
غزه ولكن هذا هذا الامر لا لا يعني انها
لن تدخل هناك كثير من المعطيات على العموم
هذا ايضا شاهدناه في خان يونس عندما وصلت
اليها ثم اعادت لترتب مواضيعها على العموم
اذا سمحت لي في موضوع خان يونس تحديدا
كانت الجزيره حصلت على مشاهد جديده
للمعارك بين كتائب القسام والجيش
الاسرائيلي في خان يونس جنوبي القطاع
وتظهر هذه المشاهد استهداف دبابات
اسرائيليه في مناطق عده من مسافات قريبه
اضافه الى قنص جنود
اسرائيليين متحصنين في بنايات مدنيه ربما
نتابع هذه اللقطه اللقطه الاولى من
الفيديو وهي احد المقاومين لديه
القاذف الياسين يستهدف دبابه مباشره من
مسافه قريبه جدا تقاس بعشرات الامتار في
الحد الاقصى بارض مجرفه ارض مجرفه نعم
وارض مكشوفه ولكنه استخدم وسائل الحمايه
والتامين الشخصي تخفي والتمويه للوصول الى
المنطقه التي تمكنه من توجيه ضربه قاتله
اللقطه الثانيه هذه دبابه ضمن مناطق مبنيه
والاستهداف تم من
خلال احد العمارات الموجوده هذه مواصفات
دبابه المير كافه تكلفتها 6 ونص مليون
تقريبا
دولار تعتبر من الاحدث في العالم يعني هذا
الفيديو واحده شاهدنا خمس دبابات من هذا
النوع
ا
د يعني الان انا ساعطي القيمه للتاثير
المادي المباشر وليس وليس للتاثير
الاقتصادي لانه انا
بيهمني ولكن هذا ب بلا شك م مؤثر لكن
القضاء على الدبابه في لحظه فارقه تمنعها
من من انجاز عمليات قد تكون مؤلمه اكيد
هذا هو رب هذا سر القتال هذه الان استهداف
دبابه من اح من من نافذه تم
استحداثها هذه اللقطه ال الشيء الجميل
فيها انها كان كانت سريعه جدا مجرد ظهوره
رمى
واختفى داخل مدرسه ب هذه مجموعه من الجنود
يبدون انهم داخل مدرسه او بناء تم رصدهم
هذا اعاده حركتهم ومن ثم تم استهدافهم ب
تبين طبيعه هذا المبنى ه مدرسه كانها
مدرسه
يعني هذه الان تحدثت سلام عن الاستخدام
الرشاشات اللي هو الكلاشنكوف وهي اشتباكات
من مسافات
قريبه هذه ما تسمى يعني الاشتباك الوجه
لوجه
شيخ صالح رحمه الله
عليه هذه اعاده للقطه
الاولى هذه عربه النمر هي على شاصي دبابه
سنتوريون مع السائق بكون والامر بكون 11 ش
الج ناقله الجند وهي محصنه ومحميه 63 طن
وزنها والتي اظهر الفيديو كانت هناك كتابه
على انها كانت محمله ن اذا اذا اعيدت
اللقطه ستكون واضحه كانت تحمل متفجرات على
الجناح الزاويه الخلفيه اليسار منها وتم
استهدافها وبالتالي نتج اثار وجود
المتفجرات اعطى شكلا مختلفا للتفجير لانه
كانت المتفجرات خارج وبالتالي اللهب كان
واضحا جدا فيما لو كان الاختراق داخلي
والت التفجير داخلي كتله اللهب تكون اصغر
الا في حال واحد في حاله الدبابات تكون
هناك انفجار الذخيره فبتالي هل هذا امر
معتاد ان تكون هناك متفجرات تحمل على ظهر
في ظروف قتال اعتقد يعني هذا الاجراء هو
اجراء لاشخاص
اجراء لاشخاص غير محترفين لا نعرف طبعا كم
عدد الجنود اللي كانوا بداخل ولكن يفترض
ان هذه ال هذه المهمات التي كانت لدى
الطاقم هكذا تقول العباره المكتوبه قد
تكون له للطاقم او لجمله اعمال عسكريه هذه
هذه دعيني اقول هي بقايا الاشتباكات هذه
ما كانت ممتلكات جنود جيش الاحتلال نعم
على العموم اذا هذا احد الفيديوهات التي
تابعناها اليوم ولكن كان هناك فيديو اخر
بثته كتائب القسام لاطلاق رشقه صاروخيه من
قطاع غزه باتجاه اسرائيل وافاد مراس
الجزيره بان صافرات الانذار دوت في نتيف
حسره في غلاف غزه الشمالي نتابع هذا
الفيديو اذا هل هناك ما يلفتك في هذا يعني
الان التوقيت يعني هذه جاءت بعد 100 يوم
من بدء الطوفان الاقصى وبعد 100 يوم من
الحمله الجويه اكثر من 66 يوم من الحمله
البريه برغم كل الدمار رغم كل ما قيل
ويقال عن المنطقه الشماليه ان يتم اطلاق
الصواريخ مرتين وليس مره واحده كتائب
القسام اطلق الدفعه وبعدها
بساعتين سرايا القدس اطلقت دفعه ثانيه مما
يدل انه القواء المقاومين لا يزالوا م بما
انك تحدثت عنها لا ادري فقط شاهدنا اذا
هذا الفيديو لكتائب القسام الرشق
الصاروخيه باتجاه غلاف غزه وكانت هناك كما
اشار اللواء فايز فيديو اخر عرضته سرايا
القدس لمشاهد من العمليه المشتركه التي
نفذها مقاتلو سرايا القدس
وكتائب الاقصى لواء العمودي وتضمنت
المشاهد قصف تجمع اليات وجنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وسط خان يونس جنوبي القطع
نتابع يعني هذا في الجزء الجنوبي المنطقه
الجنوبيه تتميز ب وجود لواء خان يونس
القسام وقوات النخبه من الفصائل الاخرى
وبالتالي كان كافه الفصائل تشارك في معركه
خان يونس وتم انشاء غرفه عمليات مشتركه
لاداره العمل المشترك ليس لاداره عمل
القسام لوحده لا هناك غرفه عمليات مشتركه
القياده في منطقه خانيونس تميل الى الى
المركزيه اكثر منها في معركه شمال القطاع
في مدينه غزه لانه كانت تميل الى
اللامركزيه بسبب تعدد الوحدات والنطاق
الجغرافي لكل وحده الذي تدافع عنه فكنا
نقول كتيبه التفاح كتيبه الشجاعيه كتيبه
الان نقول لواء خان يونس سرايا القدس
وكتائب الشهيد ابو علي مصطفى وغيرها
وبالتالي تم تفعيل غرفه العمليات المشتركه
لكافه الفصائل حتى لا يكون هناك تعارض
وتضارب في اداء القتال الميداني و بلا شك
يعني تتالي هذه الفيديوهات بهذه الصوره في
اليوم المئه للحرب بلا شك رساله اذا قويه
لاسرائيل التي تفاجات بوجود من المؤكد
يعني بعد 100 يوم من القتال لا تزال
الفصائل قادره على ضبط ايقاع المعركه رغم
فارق القوه هذا امر مثير للدهشه شكرك
جزيلا لواء فايز دوير ك المعتاد شكرا
جزيلا لك